New perplexity computer plus notebook LM
is insane. Today I'm going to show you a
combo that changes everything. One AI
thinks, the other one acts. Put them
together and you get a full business
workflow built in minutes. This is brand
new. It is stupidly easy. And by the end
of this video, you are going to wonder
why you are still doing things the old
way. Hey, stick around because what I
show you at the end is going to blow
your mind. All right, let me break this
down super simple. You know, perplexity,
right? that AI search tool that gives
you answers with sources. It is great.
But they just dropped something way
bigger. It is called Perplexity Computer
and it does not just answer questions.
It takes action for you. It browses. It
analyzes. It builds things. It runs
multi-step tasks on its own. Think of it
like having a worker that never sleeps
and never complains. You give it a job
and it goes and does it step by step.
Now on the other side, you have got
notebook LM. This is your research
brain. You throw sources at it and it
organizes everything. It pulls out the
key points. It builds comparison tables.
It turns messy information into clean
structured intelligence. Instead of
reading 20 tabs yourself, Notebook LM
does it for you in seconds. So, here is
the magic. Notebook LM does the
thinking. Perplexity Computer does the
doing. Research plus execution. That is
the combo. And I am going to show you
exactly how to use both of them right
now. Hey, if we haven't met already, I'm
the digital avatar of Julian Goldie, CEO
of SEO agency Goldie Agency. Whilst he's
helping clients get more leads and
customers, I'm here to help you get the
latest AI updates. Julian Goldie reads
every comment, so make sure you comment
below. Let us start with Notebook LM.
Step one is resource discovery. You open
up Notebook LM and you paste in a simple
prompt, something like this. I am
researching the latest strategies for
growing an AI automation community.
Automatically discover and pull the most
relevant and recent sources, including
blog posts, case studies, competitor
breakdowns, content strategies, and real
world examples. Prioritize the newest
information. Organize sources by
category. Now, watch what happens.
Notebook LM starts building your
research database automatically. You did
not Google anything. You did not open 50
tabs. It just pulls in everything and
organizes it for you. That right there
saves you hours. Step two is where it
gets really good. Now you ask notebook
LM to extract the insights. You say
something like this. From the collected
sources, summarize what the top AI
automation communities are doing, right?
What makes them grow fast? What content
formats work best? What are the gaps in
the market? Then create a comparison
table showing how the AI profit
boardroom stacks up against the
competition. Boom. You get a clean
breakdown. You get a comparison table.
You can see exactly where you stand and
where the opportunities are. This is not
guesswork. This is structured
intelligence built from real data. Now,
step three, you take all of that
research and you turn it into a plan.
You tell Notebook LM to create a
step-by-step workflow. Something like
this. Using everything we have learned,
create a practical action plan for the
AI profit boardroom. include how to find
the right audience, how to position
against competitors, how to create a
content strategy that drives traffic,
how to structure a landing page that
converts, make it actionable and
concise, and just like that, you've got
a full strategic plan sitting right in
front of you. Notebook LM did all the
heavy lifting. All you did was ask the
right questions. And one more thing, if
you are creating all this content with
Notebook LM, but nobody is finding it
online, you have got a traffic problem.
That is where SEO comes in. If you want
more leads, more traffic, and more
customers, my team can help you rank
higher on Google. Check the link in the
comments and description to order AICO
online and let us handle your back links
while you focus on growing your
business. And if you want to rank number
one and get more customers, join the SEO
elite circle. That is where we actually
teach you how this works. No theory, no
recycle tips, just the exact AI SEO
systems we are using right now. We break
everything down step by step with real
workflows. weekly live support and clear
actions you can follow without guessing.
If you are serious about scaling with
SEO and AI, this is where you start. Hit
the link in the description and join the
SEO elite circle today. Okay, now here's
where it gets crazy. This is the part I
was telling you about. We are going to
take everything Notebook LM built and
hand it off to Perplexity Computer. This
is the execution engine. Watch this. You
open up Plexity Computer inside
Perplexity AI and you give it a prompt
like this. Act as an AI operator.
Research the best ways to grow the AI
profit boardroom community in 2026.
Identify the top five competitors in the
AI automation education space. Analyze
their strengths and weaknesses. Find the
content gaps in the market. Create a
unique positioning angle for the AI
profit boardroom. Generate a complete
content strategy. Outline a landing page
structure that highlights the value of
AI automation and explains all the
benefits of the community. Write the
landing page copy. Then create a 30-day
content calendar. Execute each step in
sequence and show your reasoning
clearly. Now sit back and watch. This is
the insane part. Perplexity computer
starts browsing the web on its own. It
is pulling data. It is analyzing
competitors. It is finding gaps. Then it
starts building. It writes out a full
content strategy. It drafts a landing
page that talks about why the AI profit
boardroom is the place to learn AI
automation. It lays out a 30-day
calendar with topics and formats. All of
it done automatically. Let me say that
again. It researched a niche, analyzed
competitors, found opportunities, built
a strategy, wrote landing page copy, and
created a content calendar all from one
prompt. That is not the future. That is
right now. Now, think about what we just
did. Notebook LM gathered the
intelligence. It organized everything.
It built a strategic plan. Then,
Perplexity Computer took that plan and
executed it. research to strategy to
execution to finished assets. That is a
full workflow that used to take days,
maybe weeks, and we just did it in
minutes. And this works for anything.
Want to launch a new product, same
workflow. Want to plan a content series,
same workflow. Want to analyze a new
market, same workflow. The combo is the
same every time. Notebook LM thinks
perplexity computer acts. Now, here is
what most people get wrong. They use one
tool at a time. They search for
something on Perplexity. They read stuff
on Notebook LM, but they never connect
the two. That is like having a brain and
hands but never using them together.
When you chain these tools, the output
is 10 times better than using either one
alone. Let me give you one more example
to make this real. Say you want to
create a new lead magnet for the AI
profit boardroom. You go to notebook LM
first. You ask it to research the top
performing lead magnets in the AI
education space. It pulls in examples
and organizes them. Then you ask it to
identify what format works best and what
topics get the most engagement. Now you
have got your research. Then you go to
perplexity computer. You tell it to take
that research and create a full outline
for a lead magnet about AI automation
workflows. Write the intro, draft the
key sections, suggest a title that grabs
attention and build a simple landing
page outline to promote it. Done. You
just created a full lead magnet strategy
without writing a single word yourself.
That is the power of this combo. And
honestly, we are just scratching the
surface. These tools are going to keep
getting better. the people who learn how
to use them now are going to be so far
ahead of everyone else. So, here's what
I want you to do. Go try this yourself.
Open Notebook LM, run the research
prompts I showed you, then take it to
Perplexity computer and let it execute.
You will be shocked at what comes out.
And one more thing, if you are creating
all this content with Notebook LM, but
nobody is finding it online, you have
got a traffic problem. That is where SEO
comes in. If you want more leads, more
traffic, and more customers, my team can
help you rank higher on Google. Check
the link in the comments and description
to order AI SEO online and let us handle
your back links while you focus on
growing your business. And if you want
to rank number one and get more
customers, join the SEO elite circle.
That is where we actually teach you how
this works. No theory, no recycle tips,
just the exact AI SEO systems we are
using right now. We break everything
down step by step with real workflows,
weekly live support, and clear actions
you can follow without guessing. If you
are serious about scaling with SEO and
AI, this is where you start. Hit the
link in the description and join the SEO
elite circle today. I will see you in
the next